[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يقفون امام عابر السبيل في الطريق السريع
ويمنعونهم من العبور قطع الطريق
اعاده في السودان لاكرام المسافرين في
رمضان يحرس السودانيون خلال الشهر الكريم
على الخروج بالطعام والشراب الى الشوارع
وتناولهما في تجمعات مع الماره وعابر
السبيل على جانبي الطريق وتجري هذه العاده
خصوصا في قريه الجديد عمران بولايه
الجزيره حيث ينزل المسافرون من سياراتهم
لتناول الافطار قبل مواصله رحلاتهم عندنا
يعني دي اهم حاجه في رمضان كوننا نستقبل
اكبر كميه من الضيوف
وعلى جوانب شوارع
ابدا الضيوف بتناول وجبتهم الاجباريه
المكونه من التمر اولا ثم البليله والحساء
وعلى المائده ايضا اكله الويك الشهيره
وملاح الروب والقراصه وبعد تناول الطعام
الافطار يحتسي المسافرون الشاي والقهوه
قبل ان يودعوا اهل القريه الذين سيستعدون
بعدها لاداء صلاه التراويح دائما
القريه على الشارع والشارع بيجيب الناس ما
شافوه ونحن يعني
بنقدم له الوجبه الافطار دي ما ابرز عاده
رم
ضانيه سونها في بلدانكم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]